اذا كنت في الثانويه العامه وفي مصر فاحذر
الغش او حتى المحاوله في تقنيه الفار
ستكون لك بالمرصاد
تقنيه الفار الشهيره المستخدمه في تحكيم
مباريات كره القدم وتعني التحكيم بمساعده
الفيديو والتي تعتمد على مراجعه القرارات
التي يتخذها حكموا المباراه باستخدام
لقطات فيديو وسماعه راس للتواصل مع الحكم
المساعد المتواجد امام الشاشه عند الضروره
سوف تستخدم هذه المره لضبط الغشاشين في
امتحانات الثانويه العامه في مصر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فقد اعلن وزير التربيه والتعليم المصري
انه سيتم تشغيل تقنيه الفيديو الشهيره
داخل اللجان امتحان الثانويه العامه هذا
العام وكشف عن مزايا هذه التقنيه مؤكدا
انها ستساعد اللجنه المركزيه الامتحانات
الثانويه العامه في متابعه اللجان بشكل
لحظي وضبط اي محاولات للغش كما سيتم
استخدام العسل الالكترونيه في تفتيش
الطلاب قبل وبعد دخولهم للجان فيما ستعتبر
حيازه الهاتف حتى وان مغلقا جريمه تستوجب
رسوب الطالب سنه كامله
[موسيقى]